well privilege isn't beta works the only
problem there's also his taste in art as
a teenager he went by the hacker
nickname psychedelic warlord has he
dropped acid that is actually a good
question to ask beta and hope somebody
will whether he was doing that or not he
did write a poem about cows
now to be clear bado is a poet he's an
artist and we don't to be disrespectful
to his art so we're not gonna Boulder
eyes this we're just gonna read his
words and again these are his not ours
we would not add capital letters to in
EE Cummings poem and we're not gonna
change Beto's poem but it's a little bug
or so if you don't want to hear it close
your ears here it is
I need a but shine right now you are a
holy o sacred cow I thirst for you
provide milk buff my balls love the cow
good fortune for those that do love me
breathe my feet the cow has risen end
quote
author and columnist mark Stein
struggling mightily to keep a straight
face joins us tonight mark how would you
how was how would you rate betta works
poetry on a scale of 100 points
oh come on worried Keats and Shelley
territory here I love the rhyme I love
the meter I love the poetic sentiment
about buffing whatever particular aspect
of bate oh it was personally I'd be
privileged to buff any part of bate oh
but this cow is being invited to buff
the essence of bait oh that in itself is
a beautiful poetic sentiment and I love
date ladder too and I have to say I
thought that was absolutely delightful
to say that diversity and identity means
we have to put up lots of black and gay
and Muslim and transgender candidates so
they could lose to the rich white guy
pads that seem to be don't rational now
that's what they really think that's
actually the plan yes yes the thing
about it is I don't believe in the
concept of white privilege but these
guys do and actually it's hard to get
more white privileged than a judges
boarding school son who's writing bovine
poetry of the kind you just quoted and
is and is the world's most dedicated
middle-aged skateboarder you mentioned
the other night Tucker that they were
all hailing him as the new rock star and
in our insane world that when it comes
to political candidates it seems to be
you're either the new boy band or the
new headline creasing Lee there's
nothing in between so if you're trumping
the new Hitler and baito is the BAE the
boy band du jour and of course all boy
bands are du jour but there's there's
something slightly pathetic in being in
being in a being a political boyband
when you're pushing 50 and still
skateboarding around like the the rich
the rich white kid doing bovine poetry
back when when you were getting your
picked up on DWI and burglary charges
this this is actually a parody of rich
white privilege I would like to apply
the standards of identity politics to
the people who espouse them and if I
could pass one law it would be that you
would not be allowed to nominate bit
over work in the Democratic Party
because it's contrary to what you say
you believe absolutely and if he was the
hue if he had an hour after his name he
would be george w bush he would be the
the rich white kid from Texas with the
DWI charge all that all that is
different such that he's got a D after
his name instead of an R that is so
smart I hadn't even thought of that
that's that's why I love having Mark
Steyn you always think of it thank you
good to see you
thanks a lot Tucker great to be with you